[Music]
foreign
there is no way to begin today's daily
cancellation except to dive right into
it uh here's the Yahoo news report it
says comedian Jordan gray stripped naked
on Channel 4 as part of the revived
special episode of Friday Night Live the
80s comedy series returned for a one-off
episode on Friday uh on Friday 21st of
October as part of the Channel's 40th
anniversary celebrations
Ben Elton was back at the helm whoever
that is along with former Friday Night
Live cast members Enfield brand and
Julian Clary the comic who is trans
performed a rendition of the song Better
Than You from her critically acclaimed
Edinburgh Fringe show is it a bird at
the end of the song gray who completed
competed on The Voice in 2016 shouted
out the best thing about live TV is I
can do stupid stuff like this after
improvising on the keyboard she then ran
across the stage and stripped completely
naked to Applause and cheers from the
audience before returning to the
keyboard and playing it with her penis
with her penis
I mean that whole sentence
she played the piano with her penis
imagine someone like from 15 years ago
come arriving here in a time machine and
the first sentence they read is that
now there's a video that goes along with
this story but I will spare you such
Horrors
um you need not suffer as I have
suffered in fact I became aware of this
story as I was scrolling down my Twitter
feed on Saturday and the video
um popped up and started playing
assaulting my eyeballs and my soul
without my consent
this is by the way one of the many
reasons you should keep your kids off of
social media if you aren't already and
perhaps keep yourself off of it also uh
social media
subjects us to lots of imagery that we
do not want to see and certainly did not
have in mind when we opened the app and
started scrolling just a constant stream
of ugliness and filth and insanity and
many other kinds of awful depressing
things thanks the internet we've all
seen things
that no human being should ever have to
see traumas that the human mind was not
made to withstand burdens it was not
intended to carry and this story
provides a good example of that sort of
thing in fact forget about social media
this degenerate Predator did this on
live television with children in
physical attendance in the auditorium
and also watching on TV
he exposed himself to kids and to plenty
of other people who did not consent to
it he is a predatory creep who should be
in prison
but instead he is of course being
celebrated by the left the independent
uh the outlet the independent went so
far as to call the the indecent exposure
episode bold hilarious and get this
life-changing it was life-changing to
see this guy
um playing the piano with his penis many
other Leftovers on social media echoed
the sentiment extolling the grotesque
repulsive site with the sorts of glowing
adjectives usually reserved for
something like the Sistine Chapel
vastly overcompensating in their efforts
to pretend that they weren't as grossed
out as the rest of us were
which I can guarantee you most of them
in fact work
I think this all reveals two things
well there was something else that was
revealed too but we aren't going to
discuss that in any detail as for the
other two
first of all if it wasn't already clear
to you it should now hopefully be
apparent that the days of leave us alone
and stay out of our private lives are
over and they've been over for a long
long time in fact those days never
really existed they never started
left-wing LGBT activists pretended they
wanted us out of their bedrooms
but we were never in their bedrooms and
we never requested access to their
bedrooms every time they said get it out
of our bedrooms you know we always said
but no don't worry I'm not I'm not
coming in there don't have to worry
about that
what they really wanted and have now
succeeded in doing
is to turn the whole world into their
bedroom
to act out their sexual fantasies in
full view of the public
more than that and this is all the more
the case for Trans activists
specifically
they want us to participate in their
sexual fantasies this is the demand of
the trans activist he wants you to not
only he wants to not only to expose you
to his fantasies and fetishes but he
demands that you play a role whether you
like it or not
so here we have a trans person with an
exhibitionist fetish and everyone
watching channel 4 on Friday night and
many other Millions more who happen to
be scrolling through social media the
following day are forced to be actively
involved
just by being Witnesses by being
spectators
sexual perversion and rampant out of
control narcissism that is trans
activism in a nutshell if you'll pardon
the expression second point
I've always said that male privilege at
least in modern Western societies is a
myth
but I should update or amend that claim
because male privilege is a myth for
most men however men who identify as
women enjoy the most privilege of all in
other words the only men who have male
privilege are the men who identify as
female
now a woman who stripped her clothes
entirely off on live television would be
harshly criticized for it rightly so
and that's true even in our current age
when women who make sexual objects of
themselves are celebrated and glorified
but there are still limits however
arbitrary those limits might be a woman
who did something similar
would have her you know she'd have her
Defenders certainly no doubt but she
would have a great many critics too
and that's even more the case for
so-called quote-unquote cisgender men
otherwise known as just men if this was
if this was some dude who identified as
a dude and fully exposed himself on
television
he would be seen straightforwardly as a
predator a Harvey Weinstein type
he would be after all exposing himself
to an audience without that audience's
consent
now considering what counts as sexual
harassment these days a guy pulling his
penis out on stage and whipping it
around would without question be found
guilty of it
you can be accused of crossing the
sexual harassment line if you pay a
woman a compliment in a way that she
finds creepy or awkward or whatever so
exposing your genitals to thousands of
women all at once without their consent
would obviously obliterate that line
wherever the line is drawn so if this
was a man who identifies as a man he
would have then no Defenders anywhere
nobody would be offending
but the man
who is who is still a man and identifies
as a woman
for him it's only this this act of
sexual harassment becomes bold beautiful
life-changing
so male privilege yeah definitely that
exists with a caveat
the male with privilege is the male who
denies that he is one
and the privilege he has given is not
one that any decent human being would
want because he has the privilege of
being a narcissistic predatory
self-obsessed degenerate
and we're all meant to applaud the very
behavior that we rightly scorn when
exhibited by literally anybody else
now many people have gone along with
these rules for far too long and that's
how we've gotten to the point where a
guy who calls himself a woman would feel
entitled to take his penis out on live
television
if this is not a message to the tolerant
masses that they've been far too
tolerant and need to start being a lot
more intolerant then I don't know if
they'll ever get the message if they
don't get it now
I can only hope that this is enough
and I can say to this guy
who should be on a sex offender registry
right now
and would be if you didn't have the
trans your way out of jail free card I
could say to him you are canceled
and that'll do it for us today as we
move over to the members block of the
show hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]